après la collision de deux avions au
dessus de quiberon la compagnie
propriétaire de biche crarr qui a
percuté un cessna estime que son pilote
n'a pas respecté le règlement tour de
france l'équipe néerlandaise tvm
suspectés de dopage n'a pas pris le
départ ce matin
rodolfo massy le coureur italien de
l'équipe casino mise en examen c'est une
première après la révolte des coureurs
face aux perquisitions les policiers
font part de leur mécontentement
invité de ce journal bernard grave et
directeur central de la police
judiciaire pour le dixième mois
consécutif le chômage a baissé en juin
de 0 5% et d'après l'insee la décrue
doit se poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
les amoureux du piano se retrouve en
provence à la roque d'anthéron
rendez-vous des virtuoses du clavier du
monde entier madame monsieur bonsoir
quelques 5 millions de voitures lâché
sur les routes de france pour le
week-end le plus chargé de l'année
ceux qui partent et ceux qui reviennent
vont se croiser principalement demain
samedi classée noire en province et
rouge en ile-de-france et attention vous
l'a dit tout à l'heure pluies et orages
sont prévus sur certains axes des
vacances donc prudents les premiers
bouchons étaient signalés en début
d'après midi dans la région de bordeaux
et de biarritz ainsi que dans la vallée
du rhône que bison futé recommandé de ne
pas fréquenter entre 10h et 19h virginie
fiche et olivier jacque comme les autres
ils sont partis depuis des heures et
leur patience mérite une récompense ces
vacanciers portant grosse fourrure ou
quelques exigences tout de même pour
supporter le voyage dont 140 pays
s'inquiètent aussi
à lui d'en avoir s'arrête assez souvent
longtemps le promène souvent
moralité les jours de grands départs la
vie de chien c'est plutôt pour les
maîtres mots chaleur et découvertes et
on n'a pas de clim mais non ça va pas
trop mal je me repose simplement j'ai
pas besoin de sommeil je dormirais plus
tard à l'hôtel et au delà de la chaleur
et de la fatigue le bouchon reste le
stress numéro un du voyageur aujourd'hui
la journée avait plutôt bien commencé
les premières perturbations sérieuses
dans la vallée du rhône ne sont apparues
qu'en fin de matinée et les points noirs
sont toujours les mêmes dont ils ont des
collisions de se dire sur tout il ya pas
mal de ralentissement depuis lyon caen
surtout après vienne dans l'après midi
le trafic s'est intensifié à 17 heures
l'autoroute a7 atteignez sa limite de
saturation 5200 véhicules par heure tout
au long du parcours les automobilistes
ont régulièrement rencontrer des
ralentissements de 5,7 voire 11 km dans
les deux sens et la nuit à venir promet
d'être longue
on a des trafics de l'ordre de 3000
véhicules heure toute la nuit sur
l'autoroute alors il faut mettre en
garde les usagers qui partait nuit un
certain nombre de risques à rouler la
nuit en particulier le baisse de
vigilance la fatigue liée à une période
très difficile c'est trois heures à 6
heures du matin où il ya des risques
d'assoupissement qui deviennent
importants vigilance donc une pause
toutes les deux heures est aussi
bénéfique aux passagers à quatre pattes
qu'à son m nous rejoignons direct
virginie fichier qui se trouve entre
lyon et valence et leur virginie quelle
est la situation à l'heure actuelle et
surtout quelle sera la situation dans
les heures à venir
et bien en fait ce soir bison futé
annonce cette journée au rouge jusqu'à
21h mais est sûr certains endroits
l'accalmie risque d'être un peu plus
tardive et surtout de courte durée car
demain samedi est classé noir dès 5
heures du matin et jusqu'à au moins 18h
dans la vallée du rhône alors sachez
tout de même que les poids lourds ne
circuleront pas demain matin entre 8h et
12h
aucune dérogation ne sera accordée de
même les transports d'enfants seront
interdits sur le réseau routier
si vous êtes un peu plus patient différé
toutefois votre départ à dimanche voire
même à lundi en résumé il suivait le
dicton chuté du bison pour ce week-end
pour éviter les ennuis
laissez passer le samedi voilà bah nous
nous écouterons bison futé mais si nous
le pouvons d'ailleurs dans les aéroports
bien sûr il y avait aussi pléthore de
passagers 750 mille voyageurs doivent
transiter dans les aéroports parisiens
ce week-end 6000 avions ont été affrétés
soit 30% de plus qu'habituellement
et puis dans les gares l'atmosphère est
également l'embouteillage avec deux
millions de voyageurs la sncf a mis en
service trois mille cinq cents trains
dont 2300 tgv c'est un record historique
eric mézil bruno gérondeau montpellier
avignon valise à la main billet en poche
ils sont tous prêts pour le grand départ
il
c'est vous c'est moi c'est nous ce sont
les trois millions de voyageurs qui
prendront le train ce week-end
il ya ceux qui par ces départs de
vacances un peu pagailhous
tout va bien
on de ce qu on attend que l'affichage de
notre voie et
voilà mais c'est pas très grave
et il ya ceux qui reviennent record
historique pour la sncf qui a mobilisé
rien que pour paris 3500 train dont 2300
tgv c'est un jour exceptionnel pour la
sncf toutes les rames sont sorties étant
les personnels sont mobilisés et donc
être à cause de travailler vraiment en
qualité car il n'y a pas beaucoup de
matériel de réserve que par conséquent
tout le monde est mobilisé pour que ça
se passe bien la particularité des
trains c'est généralement de partir à
l'heure le chef de guerre a beau être
indulgent aujourd'hui quand c'est fini
c'est fini
du monde de la tohu le voyageur est vite
perdu
mais pour l'occasion la sncf a mis sur
pied l'opération veste jaune veste rouge
ça me fait plaisir soit désormais
largement mois-ci quelques parts
dans une guerre se trouve de tout des
grincheux disent qu'il y ait des gens
heureux alors à la gare de lyon un
voyageur sans bagage laurent bailly que
ça se passe pas si mal que ça finalement
ça se passe pas si mal que ça philippe
et pourtant bon 2 millions de personnes
vous l'avez dit sont attendus dans les
gares parisiennes ce week end 3 millions
de personnes ont choisi le rail ce
week-end pour voyager en france ça fait
quand même beaucoup de monde et
d'ailleurs vous pouvez le voir un peu
autour de moi ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
de monde est évidemment là cette
concentration de personnes est dû au
fait que ça ne vous a pas échappé
le 31 juillet et le 1er août cette année
tombe tard week-end
ceci explique cela et pourtant c'est
vrai on à l'ars leur la sensation d'une
relative fluidité ce soir la gare de
lyon et c'est peut-être dû au fait que
on l'a vu dans sujet d'eric masi la sncf
a mobilisé à doubler la capacité de ses
tgv a ajouté cinq six wagons par trains
corail et bien au départ de paris sur
ces destinations les plus demandées à
savoir nice et marseille ici en tout cas
cela dit que les retardataires ne se
fasse aucune illusion ce soir si on est
venue à la gare de lyon sans avoir
réservé son billet tram ne pourra pas
monter à bord d'un train ce sera encore
pire demain d'ailleurs et sauf
évidemment si on prend le risque de
voyager debout pendant des heures coincé
entre une portière et une montagne de
valises
merci laurent au large de quiberon après
la collision en plein vol de deux avions
et hier quatre nouveaux corps ainsi que
les deux boîtes noires de l'avion de
ligne beechcraft auraient été repérés
l'accident a fait 15 morts lorsque
l'appareil a heurté en plein ciel un
cessna une enquête en flagrant délit
pour homicide involontaire a été ouverte
pour déterminer précisément l'origine de
la catastrophe
henri ghesquière jean-louis querrec
nous sommes à huit kilomètres au large
de quiberon le chasseur de mines la
croix du sud vient de localiser en
milieu d'après-midi la carlingue de
l'avion beechcraft qui s'est abîmé hier
des plongeurs sont allés vérifier à 15
mètres de fond et ils ont repéré des
corps à la base de secours installés sur
l'aérodrome de quiberon
cette information est confirmée des
plongeurs ont donc investi qu'est ce
bout de carlingue et on trouvait à
l'intérieur
plusieurs corps dont certains qui sont
actuellement inaccessibles
ils sont en train de prospecter sur un
peu plus loin où se trouve également
d'autres débris moins important ce soir
les services de secours savent
exactement où repose la carlingue de
l'avion beechcraft et il y a un espoir
de retrouver assez rapidement plusieurs
corps toutefois personne n'était en
mesure d'indiquer précisément le nombre
de corps gisant au fond de l'océan et
les recherches semblent particulièrement
difficile pour les plongeurs la
visibilité s'est dégradée puisqu'au fond
de l'eau à 15 20 m à la visibilité d'un
maître en ce moment ce qui est très
difficile puisque soit nous sommes
exactement sur le
les morceaux repéré soit nous n'avons
aucune chance de les retrouver
par ailleurs le deuxième avion qui s'est
écrasé pendant l'accident un petit
cessna avait qu'une seule personne à
bord n'a pas encore été repérés enfin
les responsabilités des pilotes ne sont
toujours pas clairement défini
ce sont certainement les boîtes noires
des appareils qui révéleront les
circonstances exactes de la catastrophe
jacques devaux vous êtes sur place à qui
bon alors quels sont les derniers
éléments de l'enquêté où en sont les
recherches maintenant et bien en ce qui
concerne l' enquête le procureur de la
république jean michel fretigne et
depuis le milieu de l'après-midi à bord
du chasseur de mines la croix du sud
il est accompagné de deux enquêteurs et
a apporté avec lui des scellés ce qui
laisse à penser que les boîtes noires
ont été retrouvées mais cela ne nous a
pas été confirmé ici au pc d'autre part
le pdg de la compagnie proteus a reconnu
que son pilote était passé au vol à vue
une procédure at il précisé totalement
interdite dans sa compagnie le pdg se
refuse cependant à accabler son pilote
il estime que l'abandon du plan de vol
n'étaient pas forcément liés au survol
du norway reste une question pourquoi
ces deux appareils ne se sont ils pas vu
en vol et là le mystère demeure oui
justement la compagnie proteus vous
l'avez dit propriétaire du beechcraft
qui a percuté le cessna a donc estimé
que son pilote avait enfreint le
règlement interne en changeant de cap et
de procédure alors tout cela peut-être
pour permettre aux passagers d'admirer
le paquebot norwegian mouillé au large
de quiberon de quiberon pardon
explications romuald de bonnan et
jean-françois chevet l'arrivée du norway
l'ancien paquebot france au large de
quiberon
un spectacle suivi du ciel par une
quinzaine d'avions d'ailleurs au club
au même moment un beechcraft 1900
provenance de lyon avec douze passagers
à bord amorce sa descente vers
l'aéroport de los rios l'heure mais
avant d'atterrir le comment
bord maudit si sa trajectoire pour
survoler à son tour la baie de quiberon
et le pack soudain à moins de 900 mètres
d'altitude un cessna parti de vannes une
heure plus tôt pour rejoindre le norway
croiser la route du beechcraft le pire
se produit sous les yeux d'un
photographe survolant lui aussi la zone
dont la radio dans ton attention crash
crash crash
moi je réalise pas bien et tout de suite
le pilote m'agrippe et puis me dit
regarde devant et je regarde juste
devant moi qu'est ce que je vois et d'un
avion qui qui part en vrille à la
verticale complètement c'était le
beechcraft 1900 la de la compagnie
proteus qui vraiment mais pompey tout
droit tout droit c'est impressionnant on
a continué à tourner et au deuxième
passage et plus rien puis oglo et elle
s'est juste des débuts de sièges des
morceaux de carlingue des choses comme
ça qui est très laid à côté attention il
y a du monde dans le coin ce sont les
dernières paroles de la tour de contrôle
à l'avion dit le quelques minutes
auparavant
le pilote avait annoncé qu'il passait en
voilà du et plus aux instruments une
procédure prévue par la réglementation
de l'aviation civile est souvent
utilisée dans les cockpits juste avant
l'atterrissage
seulement voilà l'appareil n'était pas
encore en vue de l'artiste
d'autre part ce passage en vol visuel
est interdit chez protéger il faut
savoir pourquoi il va dérouter l'avion
je pars donc c'est vrai qu'avec leur oui
on peut penser que c'était point survol
mais peut-être ce que je peux dire c'est
que les vols à vue sont interdits dans
le groupe élite et une entorse au
règlement qui ne suffit pas à expliquer
le drame
les deux pilotes étaient expérimentés et
connaissaient leur devoir de vigilance
en cas de vol à vue moi ça me fait de la
peine
vous êtes très ça aurait à dire je peux
rien dire contre le collègue manque
d'attention encore aveuglement par le
soleil les boîtes noires du beechcraft
repéré par 15 mètres de fond apporteront
peut-être des éléments de réponse nous
ouvrons le chapitre du tour de france
tour de france peau de chagrin ils sont
partis 189 ils sont aujourd'hui 96 après
l'abandon ce matin de l'équipe
néerlandaise tv home mais nous y
reviendrons salles vont quand même le
vainqueur de l'étape du jour le suédois
magnus backstedt tandis que marco
pantani est toujours en jaune
florent gautreau alain poirier après
trois semaines de course on trouve
encore des courageux ou des inconscients
dès le premier kilomètre d'une étape qui
rend compte 242 françois simon est parti
comme un boulet et l'étape est lancé il
sera rattrapé mais rapidement 13 hommes
s'échappent très invités pour se
partager le gâteau
vous imaginez la scène même dans la
plaine plus moyen de se reposer associés
en attaque et je vais pourri parce que
j'ai dit ah non c'est pas possible 242
km et qu'ils attaquent au départ et puis
j'ai senti que les mecs en avait un peu
marre que ça pouvait partir donc j'y
suis allé une fois deux fois trois fois
avec thierry et puis boum d'un coup on
s'est retrouvés de vente devant avec une
obligation ne pas regarder derrière et
fond c'est un moyen de lâcher le peloton
un moyen aussi d'oublier les dernières
journée très éprouvante pour les nerfs
les treize se relaient parfaitement un
train d'enfer qui ravit spectateurs et
spectatrices les échappés vont compter
jusqu'à dix sept minutes d'avancé
le peloton ne roule pas et quand il
roule il quitte la route
c'était le jour ou jamais pour
s'échapper un homme l'a compris
bourguignons sur ses terres en bourgogne
qui essaient de partir seule une
tentative vaine
il est vite repris par le groupe des 13
qui ne musarde pas dans les vignes et de
meursault à 15 km de l'arrivée quatre
hommes s'en vont pascal de ramé est à
l'origine de l'échappée décisive le
français va même tenter de partir seul
mais il sera repris lui aussi et au
swing il est battu par le suédois de
l'efficace magnus backstedt
j'ai ma femme et le match comme on dit
vas-y fallu une journée qui fait du bien
aux coureurs une journée de plus en
jaune pour pantani qui se voit déjà à
paris voilà nous ne retrouvons pas marco
pantani
mais florent gautreau drôle d'ambiance
donc pour une fin de tour de france non
oui c'est vrai on a même une rumeur qui
circulait tout à l'heure concernant
l'équipe deutsche telekom on pensait
qu'elle quitterait la course et
finalement je rassure les supporters de
jan ullrich et de bjarne riis l'équipe
deutsche telekom ira bien jusqu'à paris
c'était une rumeur comme il en circule
beaucoup depuis quelques jours une
rumeur révélatrice de l'ambiance bizarre
effectivement de cette fin de tour les
coureurs font la course on l'a vu dans
l'étape mais ils n'ont qu'une envie
c'est d'être déjà à paris d'en finir une
fois pour toutes avec ce tour 90 vite ce
matin au départ par exemple les coureurs
et les suiveurs regarder avec anxiété le
profil de cette étape très longue de 242
kilomètres et on entendait souvent
vivement dimanche
vivement la fin du tour pour le public
c'est dur parce qu'il ne reste que 96
concurrent alors qu'ils étaient 189 au
départ à dublin
luc leblanc jalabert vire entre les
leaders français ne sont plus là mais il
ya aussi une amertume dans le peloton
qui n'a pas toujours fait montre de la
solidarité nécessaire pendant ses
affaires et ce matin une interview de
jan ullrich au quotidien allemand bild
zeitung a encore mis le feu aux poudres
parce qu'il sent les prix et l'allemand
à tout le monde il s'en est pris à
festina qui est selon lui à l'origine de
ces affaires il s'en est pris à la
police française à la justice française
et l'a même évoqué en termes très durs
l'attitude de laurent jalabert et de luc
leblanc puisque selon lui je le cite ils
ont décampé avant l'heure les a accusés
d'être parti très vite trop vite on vous
l'avez compris c'est un peloton amputés
et un peu divisé des suiveurs qui en ont
un peu ras-le-bol et qui veulent rentrer
à paris
mais attention il reste deux étapes
qu'on pourra d'ailleurs suivre sur
france 2 le contre la montre demain et
l'arrivée sur les champs elysées à paris
ce sera dimanche
en principe les 96 vont prendre le
départ demain donc vont faire le le
contre-la-montre j'imagine oui a priori
les 96 sauf évidemment et événements
médical car il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
quand même des étapes qui se courait les
coureurs peuvent abandonner aussi pour
des problèmes médicaux mais a priori les
96 qui ont fini la l'étape d'aujourd'hui
repartiront demain matin pour un contre
la montre ici en saône et loire
reparlons du tour et des affaires de
dopage donc ce matin l'équipe tv m au
centre d'une enquête sur le dopage
n'était pas sur la ligne de départ
les cinq coureurs sont entrés chez eux
en hollande il devait être interrogé par
les autorités judiciaires après
l'arrivée du tour
reste à savoir s'ils seront au
rendez-vous du juge olivier carol départ
discret pour les tv m
devant leur hôtel ce matin on effacer
les dernières traces de la présence de
cette équipe hollandaise la deuxième
après festina à s'être retrouvé dans le
collimateur de la justice pour une
affaire de dopage
un communiqué a été envoyé aux officiels
pour expliquer l'abandon un communiqué
qui nous a été adressé par l'équipe tv m
en nous disant que les cours ont eux
mêmes avaient pris la décision de partir
que mentalement et physiquement ils se
considéraient plus capable de rallier
paris dans de bonnes conditions et à
partir de là ils ont préféré renoncer
il y a deux jours les couverts tvm
s'était plaint bruyamment des méthodes
policières le peloton solidaires les
avait laissés arrivés en tête
aujourd'hui à l'aéroport de zurich ces
mêmes coureurs ne cachaient pas leur
soulagement d'être hors de portée de la
justice française
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours
est invraisemblable
tout le monde peut être emmenés par la
police nous savions que si nous
abandonnions en france la police nous
arrêtera immédiatement nous avions prévu
de nous arrêter ici vous voulez bien
continuer la course mais maintenant
qu'on est en zone neutre
j'ai plus urbain bondonny convoqué lundi
au palais de justice de reims
les couvreurs tvm ont assuré qu'ils
seraient au rendez vous après un
week-end de repos en famille autre
équipe sur le départ on sait les
espagnols eux avaient abandonné
officiellement pour montrer leur colère
l'amp est stable alors on ne peut pas
faire trente mille kilomètres par an on
mange on simplement des spaghettis des
choses mais sont légales et le problème
c'est que maintenant tout le monde est
suspect dernier repas tous ensemble le
tour c'était l'objectif suprême
désormais ce sont des étapes judiciaires
qui attendent peut-être certains d'entre
eux et bien justement rodolfo massy le
coureur de l'équipe casino soupçonné
d'avoir revendu des produits dopants au
sein du peloton a été mise en examen à
lille ce soir et il n'a pas été
incarcéré le médecin de l'équipe
espagnole
on s'est également mise en examen a été
laissée sous liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire marianne masse patrick
johnston
c'est le premier coureur mise en examen
au cours de la dernière page judiciaire
qui se jouera avant la fin de ce tour
rodolfo massy est sorti libre du palais
de justice de lille mais placé sous
contrôle judiciaire
sa libération comme vous le dites
elle est tout à fait normal au regard du
dossier il conteste les éléments qui ont
été réunies contre lui par l'accusation
il les conteste ces éléments sont
contestables
les éléments se sont les corticoïdes
trouvait avant-hier dans la chambre du
coureur de l'équipe casino est interdite
en france
les enquêteurs le soupçonnent également
d'avoir joué un rôle dans
l'approvisionnement de son équipe en
produits dopants deuxième mise en examen
aujourd'hui
nicolas terre à dos le ce médecin de
l'équipe on sait
oui qui est libre et il s'en va
dites-vous en tout cas jamais lui était
reproché d'avoir administré le moins de
produits dopants il n'est pas avéré pour
l'instant que le médecin des ondes c est
effectivement administré des substances
dopantes mais d'après l'instruction il
aurait pu faciliter l'accès des coureurs
à ces produits
c'était donc aujourd'hui la dernière
page judiciaire avant l'arrivée sur les
champs elysées mais dès la semaine
prochaine
d'autres épisodes suivront à lille se
trouve olivier galzi olivier bonsoir
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant bien écouter deux mises en
examen il faut préciser d'abord que ce
ne sont pas des mises en examen tout à
fait dans les mêmes termes nicolas terra
dos le médecin de ronces et on a été
mise en examen pour infraction à la loi
de 89 sur le dopage c'est à dire en gros
usage emploi et facilitation d'usagé de
produits dopants mais il peut quitter le
pays il peut rentrer chez lui il voit
tout simplement se tenir à l'écart du
monde cycliste pour rodolphe thomas si
c'est aussi une mise en examen pour
infraction à la loi sur le dopage mais
aussi pour importation offre et cession
de substances vénéneuses ce qui signifie
bien qu'il serait au centre d'un trafic
de produits dopants dans son équipe lui
ne peut pas quitter le territoire
français
le juge lui a donné à moi pour donner
une résidence en france où il pourra
être retrouvé alors bien sûr une mise en
examen ne signifie pas culpabilité il ya
présomption d'innocence aussi rodolfo
masini tout cela était sa défense
aujourd'hui et il a déclaré au juge
qu'il tenait sa bonne forme de séjour en
altitude au mexique et uniquement de ses
séjours
merci beaucoup alors donc après la
révolte des coureurs à cause d enquête
sur le dopage on les entendu ces jours
derniers ce sont les policiers qui
réagissent dans un instant nous
entendrons bernard grave est le patron
de la police judiciaire qui donnera son
avis sur les critiques émises ces jours
derniers par certains protagonistes du
tour
après ce que j'ai fait mes déclarations
ils m'ont descendu dans la prison en
dessus j'ai dû me déshabiller
vêtements ils m'ont fouillé tout le
corps et puis ils ont envoyé dans la
cellule il n'y avait qu'une planche pour
dormir
et puis je suis resté là quand je ne
savais pas pour combien de temps
la nuit a été longue longue interminable
pendant cette nuit j'ai entendu les
autres crier dans les autres bureaux
j'ai même entendu richard vire à une
criée et je crois qu'aucun homme ne peut
rester insensible à soweto à de telles
pressions
on est resté 24 heures en garde à vue
c'est 7 8 heures d'interrogatoire
ensuite déshabillé fouillé dans un trou
dans une cellule avec une lumière qui
nous empêche de dormir
c'est ces conditions aucun courant dans
le peloton jusqu'à présent les a subi et
personne ne s'en est soucié en tout cas
bonsoir bernard grave et directeur
central de la police judiciaire alors
quand on écoute ses critiques on se dit
que ce sont les policiers qui ont gâché
la fête du tour est d'accord vous
devinez que nous je remercie de
l'opportunité que vous m'offrez de dire
que les policiers du srpj de lille de
reims qui ont travaillé sur ces affaires
sont blessés dans leur dignité
lorsqu'ils entendent certains propos
exagérés disproportionnée comme certains
que nous d'entendre voire même
diffamatoire
il ya les conditions de la garde à vue
puisque c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
on était normal la garde à vue est une
mesure de protection de l'individu dans
le cadre de la rétention de police et
donc il était normal qu'elles sont de
mesures de sécurité soient prises par
les policiers qui ont la charge
une question se grave est que le public
se pose c'est pourquoi ne pas avoir
entendu la fin du tour pour faire toutes
ces enquêtes pourquoi l'avoir fait pan
dans les villes étapes notamment la
question peut être posée mais la réponse
est évidente
vous devinez bien que face à des
déclarations claires et nettes
le juge d'instruction les juges
d'instruction avaient le souci de
verrouiller leur dossier c'est-à-dire de
vérifier tant qu'il était encore
possible
la présence éventuelle de drogue ou
d'autres produits dans les bagages des
individus
et c'était donc ce n'est pas après le
tour de france qu'on allait trouver dans
les camions qui étaient partis ou
reparti à l'étranger alors tout est
parti des interrogatoires de l'équipe tv
m
albertville aucun tact ont ils dit en
sortant de l'hôtel de police et de
l'hôpital
on n'a pas eu le temps de manger on n'a
pas le temps de se doucher de dormir
donc effectivement on a l'impression que
ce sont quand même des sportifs il avait
fait un gros effort et que disons on
s'est un peu jouer de bien pour être
bref je dirais que tout cela est faux
ils ont pu se doucher ils ont pu se
changent ils ont eu à mon âge ils ont pu
se déplacer vers l'hôpital dans leurs
propres véhicules
ils ont été gelée dire traiter avec
certains égards par des policiers qui
étaient en nombre pour préciser non
raccourcir le temps de la rétention
n'ont pas été gardés à vue
contrairement ce qu'on a dit ils ont été
simplement accompagné à l'hôpital pour
les prélèvements qu'ils avaient accepté
de bon gré alors tout cela nous paraît
faire beaucoup de bruit pour des choses
qui sont beaucoup plus simples et je
crois qu'il est grand temps que en
dehors de la polémique de lordat passion
qui anime certains pour des raisons
peut-être peu avouables il est grand
temps que l'on retrouve la sérénité et
la raison que la justice puisse
continuer à travailler avec ces
auxiliaires les policiers mais vous
reconnaissez que de temps en temps il se
peut que les policiers n'est pas
toujours le tact nécessaire non ça peut
arriver ça quand même c'est évident
qu'ils personne n'est à l'abri de ce
genre de dérapages je peux vous garantir
que nous avions conscience dans cette
affaire d'avoir à faire non pas à des
malfaiteurs mais à des gens qui devaient
être précisément ménagers nous savons
très bien que nous avons affaire à des
stars à des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude d'avoir affaire à la police
et heureusement ni à la justice
nous les avons traités cocktail croyez
moi monsieur graver une petite question
que je pour certainement les gens est ce
que le toucher rectal est vraiment une
méthode indispensable dans ce genre d'
enquête franchement puisqu'on en a
beaucoup parlé des cette mesure
s'inscrit dans l'ensemble des modalités
des mesures de sécurité qui sont prises
par ceux qui ont la charge de la garde à
vue dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est
une mesure protectrice de l'intéressé
car il faut savoir que parfois il y a
garde à vue des accidents la personne
peut perdre les pédales comme dit je
voudrais pas faire un autre jeux de mots
et on aurait certainement reprocher aux
policiers de ne pas avoir pris toutes
les mesures de protection de l'intéressé
je vous remercie beaucoup fin du
chapitre sur le tour de france
nous passons à autre chose alain
afflelou a été mise en examen pour recel
d'escroquerie par le juge vichnievsky
dans le cadre d'une enquête sur des
malversations présumées dans une banque
de placement italienne monsieur afflelou
a été laissé en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire
alban nicosie alain afflelou avait été
entendu la semaine dernière ici pendant
près de trente heures à nanterre à la
sous direction des affaires économiques
et financières
à l'ordre du jour ses rapports avec le
fondo sociale dit coopération en europe
à une petite banque de placement
italiennes soupçonnaient d'être à
l'origine d'une escroquerie évaluée à
120 millions de francs or 20 millions
ont été versés en 92 aux girondins de
bordeaux dont le président était à
l'époque justement alain afflelou à la
sortie de la garde à vue
ses avocats étaient pourtant optimiste
il a toujours eu le souci explique et
très complètement c'est ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui et c'est précisément parce
que ses explications étaient
convaincante par les orques les peurs
qu'il a été remis en liberté en début de
semaine autour des italiens d'être
entendu par le juge
wisniewski qui a mis alain flou en
examen pour recel d'escroquerie pour le
dixième mois consécutif le chômage a
reculé au mois de juin de 0 5% le nombre
des demandeurs d'emplois représente
désormais 11 8% de la population active
et d'après l'insee la baisse va se
poursuivre françoise david
le tracé de la courbe de la teste depuis
juillet 97 le chômage diminue en france
pour le seul mois de juin 98 on
enregistre un recul de 0 5% 2 millions
neuf cent soixante cinq mille quatre
cents personnes sont à la recherche d'un
emploi contre 3 million deux cent mille
il ya un an soit une baisse de cinq
points
la croissance repart la demande
intérieure et donc plus forte les
entreprises se sont mises à produire
plus et certaines ont besoin de bras
elles ont embauché mais bon nombre
d'entre elles ont cependant choisi
l'intérim
les entreprises de travail temporaire se
frotte les mains l'emploi intérimaire a
augmenté de près de 40 % en un an
les chefs d'entreprise ils trouvent leur
compte
j'appelle la personne j'appelle la boîte
d'intérim et je lui dis voilà il me faut
un manutentionnaire caris je peux
l'avoir je me dis dans l'heure qui suit
alors que si jean beauchesne il faudrait
un roi une semaine avant que je recrute
la personne on relève aussi une forte
baisse du nombre de faillites et le
nombre de licenciements économiques
décroît également l'impact des emplois
jeunes est aussi à prendre en compte 74
mille personnes ont déjà bénéficié de ce
nouveau type de contrat de travail
para public l'ait fait 35 heures restent
encore modestes
si à ce jour 80 entreprises ont signé
des accords de réduction du temps de
travail avec embauches à la clé
le nombre d'emplois créés n'excède pas
le petit milieu le viagra 7 pilules
contre l'impuissance sera vendu en
france en octobre annoncé ce soir
bernard kouchner le secrétaire d'état à
la santé
ce que l'on ne sait pas si le viagra
sera remboursé par la sécurité sociale
ou non les cote de confiance du
président de la république et du premier
ministre n'en finissent pas de grimper
d'après le baromètre mensuel sofres
figaro magazine +7 points pour jacques
chirac à 50 9% et +8 points pour lionel
jospin à 71% pour l'heure monsieur
jospin entame deux semaines de vacances
en grèce dans une île des cyclades
alors que le président chirac se repose
sur l'île maurice et puis thomson
multimédia numéro quatre mondial de
l'électronique grand public va être
partiellement privatisée quatre grands
groupes internationaux vont devenir
actionnaire à 30% dont l'américain
microsoft patron bill gates sébastien
vibert thomson multimédia je le répète
ça vaut un franc symbolique
après recapitalisation parce que dans
l'état actuel des choses ça ne vaut rien
automne 96 alain juppé premier ministre
vient malgré lui de condamner son propre
projet de cd thomson multimédia au sud
coréen daewoo aujourd'hui l'entreprise
va mieux grâce surtout aux 11 milliards
d'argent public versé l'an passé par
l'état le gouvernement jospin a donc
décidé de vendre 30% du capital 4 parts
égales pour le japonais nec le français
alcatel et les américain directv et
microsoft
moi ce qui m'intéresse en tant que
responsable au niveau du gouvernement de
la stratégie industrielle
cbe
de monter des entreprises françaises qui
soit capable d'affronter le vent du
grand large sur les technologies de
demain
la direction de thomson multimédia a
contacté 35 sociétés non pas des
concurrents comme des ou mais plutôt des
partenaires potentiels pour signer
finalement quatre protocoles d'accords
industriels
il apporte des technologies il apporte
des matériels
il apporte des financements il apporte
des capacités de recherche c'est ça qui
va permettre ce passage du monde de la
télé traditionnelle au monde des
terminaux multimédia nec géant mondial
des composants électroniques
alcatel fournisseur d'équipements de
télécommunication directives et pour les
programmes de télévision numérique par
satellite
microsoft numéro un mondial des
logiciels quatre alliés pour tenter de
faire de thomson multimédia le leader
d'un des marchés les plus prometteurs du
siècle prochain
le carnet de commandes d'airbus allonge
grâce à la compagnie américaine united
airlines qui confirme son intérêt pour
22 appareils supplémentaires qui
s'ajoutent aux 111 déjà commandés et
puis une autre bonne nouvelle un contrat
important également pour la france
alstom a lié au canadien bombardier va
fournir deux tgv aux états unis pour la
ligne washington/new york post aux états
unis au plus tôt en algérie pardon un
colis piégé a fait deux morts et 18
blessés près du marché populaire de la
capitale
au même moment la mission d'information
de l'onu en algérie continue son travail
sur le terrain pour la première fois un
des membres de cette commission madame
simone veil répond aux questions de nos
envoyés spéciaux
reportage demande wang li commentée par
thierry thuillier vendredi en algérie
ces congés et les familles en profitent
normalement pour faire leurs courses
le marché était donc bondé quand la
bombe posée près de ce pylône a explosé
le bilan officiel est de deux morts et
de 18 blessés évacués dans les hôpitaux
de la ville
quelques heures après l'attentât les
habitués du marché de kouba un quartier
populaire d'alger ne comprenait toujours
pas nos enfants sont morts que
voulez-vous que je vous dise
ce sont des pauvres gens qui viennent
faire leurs courses que ceux qui sont
dans leur mercedes noire vient de voir
des carnages ils veulent pas tuer ont
personnellement il va tuer des centaines
des milliers pour qu'elle soit médiatisé
qu'on fait maintenant
après une accalmie les attentats ont
donc repris à alger au moment même où la
mission de l'onu poursuit son travail
d'information hier
simone veil et les cinq autres membres
de la délégation onusienne ont pu se
rendre dans le village d'aïn khelil dans
l'ouest du pays à une ré l'île est un de
ces lieux martyrs dévastée par les
groupes armés pour simone veil qui
s'exprime pour la première fois les
motivations du tueur reste difficile à
comprend pas dissidents d'analyser les
raisons d'un pourquoi on s'attaque à
quelle famille at-elle ferme c'est pour
faire du chantage sur scène pour
chantage nation à son retour la mission
doit remettre un rapport très attendu
notamment sur la question des droits de
l'homme un sujet qu alger a toujours
refusé d'aborder devant la communauté
internationale à paris l'unesco a été
aujourd'hui le théâtre d'une rencontre
tout à fait exceptionnelle celle d'un
preneur d'otages iranien avec un ex
otages américains
dix neuf ans après la prise d'otages de
l'ambassade des etats-unis à téhéran
les deux hommes ont accepté de se parler
une décision personnelle
jean-marc il use olivier robert
à gauche barry rosen l'ex otage
américains à téhéran et visiblement
tendu mais il fera quand même le premier
geste à droite
abbas abdi l'iranien est l un des
principaux instigateurs de la prise
d'otages de 52 diplomates américains
c'était en novembre 79
une poignée d'étudiants révolutionnaire
venait au nom de l'imam khomeiny
d'occuper l'ambassade des etats-unis à
téhéran pour exigé l'extradition du shah
d'iran
réfugié en amérique pour tenter
aujourd'hui de combler le fossé qui
sépare depuis 20 ans leurs deux pays
les deux anciens adversaires avaient
donc décidé officiellement sans
consulter leur gouvernement respectif de
tenter à paris de mettre fin je cite à
la démagogie et aux clichés l'américain
en reconnaissant certains les excès de
la politique de son pays
mais en dénonçant les violences faites
aux otages et à leur famille pendant 444
jours
l'iranien pour expliquer que son pays
avait été lui 25 ans l'otage des états
unis en 53 washington avait organisé un
coup d'état et ramener le chat au
pouvoir seul le dialogue permettrait
aujourd'hui de tourner la page
à l'évidence c'est la décision la plus
difficile que j'ai eu à prendre depuis
20 ans mais vous voyez
j'avais vraiment besoin de boucler la
boucle de mai 444 jours de détention
l'objectif principal a été atteint que
cet échange ait vraiment pu avoir lieu
surprenant mais pas pour qui connaît
liront la morale de l'histoire fut un
extrait d'un grand poète iranien saadi
mais c'est l'américain qui su le dire en
persan
parlons musique c'est un festival à park
celui de la roque d'anthéron entre aix
et avignon
un rendez vous consacré exclusivement au
piano qui rassemble depuis 17 ans des
milliers de fidèles et les plus grands
interprètes viennent dans ce petit
village de provence donné un récital au
milieu des platanes louis carzou et
franck vaillant
à l'heure des grandes transhumances et
les pianos et leurs suites fidèles
prennent depuis 17 ans la route d'un
village de provence la roque d'anthéron
coup platanes et mistral semblent
réunies pour applaudir l'élite
internationale du clavier ainsi la
soliste brigitte engerer ne manqueraient
pour rien au monde ce festival unique
unique comme un amour de vacances
c'est vrai qu'il ya un public tout à
fait spécial un public qui aime beaucoup
le piano est abusif qui vient avec joie
avec bonheur qui vient rechercher une
émotion positive qui ne vient pas là
pour vous juger ou pour simplement parce
qu'ils ont un abonnement à une série de
concerts on sent qu'ils enfilaient km
sont amenés à vous écouter qui sont déjà
heureux d'être là
et
même si c'est sa dixième participation à
la roque d'anthéron jidong 20 prépare
son récital comme un concert capitale
car pour cette pianiste habitué aux ors
des grandes salles la musique classique
et ses interprètes doivent beaucoup
ces festivals je pense qu'ils ont ils
ont un petit peu démystifier le côté
sacré comme ça de l'amérique latine qui
faisait qu'ailleurs qui fait qu'il ya
plusieurs années les gens avaient un
petit peu peur d'aller au contraire il
avait l'impression que c'était des lieux
très fermé et qui était réservé à une
élite connaissant parfaitement la le
langage de la musique classique alors
c'est pas le langage des émotions
et
sans rien céder sur le style du
répertoire où la qualité sonore
ce festival réussi pendant deux mois
entre parties de pétanque et feu
d'artifice à fidéliser un large public
autour du piano et le soir du concert de
brigitte engerer même les grillons de la
roque d'anthéron saluer cette présence
par leur silence
avant de clore ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres tour de
france l'équipe néerlandaise tvm
suspectés de dopage n'a pas pris le
départ ce matin et rodolfo massy le
coureur italien de l'équipe casino mise
en examen c'est une première et puis
après la collision de deux avions dessus
de quiberon la compagnie propriétaire du
beechcraft qui a percuté un cessna
estime que son pilote n'a pas respecté
le règlement interne
voilà dans un instant la météo avec
nathalie rihouet américaine relativement
médiocre et puis le point route avec
valérie maurice indispensable
aujourd'hui bien évidemment je vous
souhaite à tous une très bonne soirée
sur france 2 je vous retrouve demain
pour le journal de 20h
bienvenue dans le